it's my second day at Lanterna where I'm
trying to drag it back from the depth of
despair
alex has told me he started everything
he can to save the business enjoyable
evening for every occasion only the very
best will do the kitchens are [ __ ]
dirty filthy mess exquisite classic
Italian food
God bought his [ __ ] spook radio ad is
gonna take a lot more than that to get
this place back on track when was the
last time the fridges were done last
week that finish tree from Saturday
nights that's just a special order I'm
shocked by the levels of Hygiene here I
wouldn't serve that to a [ __ ] plane
you know that Alex isn't even following
the basic rules there's got to be
macking no matter what you do when a
bacon sandwich - a [ __ ] totally near
[ __ ] goes cheese you have to stay
immaculate ovens should be clean after
every service the floor should be
spotless and leftover food should be
thrown away or stored in clearly
labelled containers more place oh [ __ ]
you know whose fingers have been in
there I need my food stuff away because
I'm nervous yeah yeah yeah with
standards this look Alex is authentic
Italian kitchen look at that in the hand
could be closed down environmental
health no pest control what me do we
need you come in one saving grace
they've never had rats or mice in this
kitchen but there is one pest I'd like
to control and that's bollocks
he's been scurrying around in his own
mess for far too long can you see where
we are now you know I've had a very
embarrassing dinner I've come back into
the kitchen the place is in a mess
you've taken your eye off the ball the
passion is gone and we've really got to
get this thing back up let's get all
that clean without any [ __ ] with a
clean kitchen I can focus on the main
problem Alex is cooking
my fame is clearly and really fortunate
an imitation of 1970s Italian crap
because when you walk into kitchen is
Bob a bottle of lazy lemon
it means lazy bastard nothing more for
me I'd only wait to [ __ ] start with
the food yeah because what I want to do
is try and stall that kind of freshness
and give it a sense of an Italian style
influence yeah but your tallien food
wasn't built up on [ __ ] frozen food
run under water
yeah just quite frankly all of seen
doing so far is reheat things I know the
food's rubbish but I need to see how he
gets it on the plate
I've never seen a chef work that has
played in our speed and yet achieved so
little
[ __ ] you know and it will fuch has got
all the energy in the world
Britta's channeled in the wrong
direction because he's actually jumping
around doing [ __ ] all
he looks [ __ ] busy but he's actually
cooking [ __ ] badly [ __ ] vodka beer
of my record with a diet of five red
balls a day alex is so wide he bashes
out the food as though his life depends
on it
most of his food comes in frozen or from
a packet and I know why he's lazy
instead of getting ready for his
customers
I'd rather play golf all day and then
rock up an hour before service with his
best mate
Gavin Swire's the restaurant manager the
face lantern but it looks like a diner
it is operated with about as much
finesse as the kitchen you say you want
to run it as this hello question well
maybe 30 years ago I can understand why
this is exist but not now inquiries are
the only further is it
nowhere near not with those yeah that
those yeah chef that's total [ __ ]
because there's nothing to tell you in
there nothing anywhere